can actually ask you uh really as
another tangent the Jared and others uh
they're doing undercover in terms of the
tools you have
for catching cyber security criminals
how much of is undercover undercover is
a high bar to jump over you have to do a
lot to start an undercover in the FBI
there's a lot of thresholds
um so it's not your first investigative
tool step you have to identify a problem
and then show that the lower steps can't
get you there
um but I mean I think we we had an
undercover going on the squad about all
times when one was being shut down or
taken down we were spinning up another
one so it's a good tool to have
um you know and utilize they're a lot of
work I don't think if you run one you'll
never run another one in your life
oh so it's like psychologically is it
there's a lot of work just technically
but also psychologically like you have
to really uh it's 24 7 you're inside
that world like you have to know what's
going on and what's happening you you
know you're taking on you have to
remember who you are when you're because
you're you're a criminal online
you have to go to a special school for
it too was that ever something
compelling to you I went through the
school but I'm pretty open and honest
guy and so it's tough for me to to Build
That Wall of Lies
um it's maybe I'm just not smart enough
to keep all the lies straight yeah but a
guy who's good at building up a wall of
Lies would say that exact same exactly
it's so annoying the way truth Works in
this world it's like uh I think people
have told me like because I'm trying to
be honest and transparent that's exactly
what an agent would do right
um but I feel like an agent would not
wear a suit and tie
I wore a suit and tie every day
I was a suit and tie guy you were yeah
every day I remember one time I wore
shorts in and the sac came in and this
was when I was I was a rock star at the
time in the bureau and I had shorts in
and uh
um I said sorry ma'am I apologize for my
attire and she goes you could wear bike
shorts in here I wouldn't care I was
like oh [ __ ] that sounds nice
I never wore the bike shorts but yeah
but see I don't I see a suit and ties
constraining I think it's it's
liberating and so it's it's like uh
shows that you're taking the moment
seriously well not just that people
wanted it I mean people expected when
you knock you you are dressed like the a
perfect FBI agent When someone knocks in
their door that's what they want to see
they want to see what Hollywood built up
is what an FBI agent is you show up like
my friend ilwan he was dressed always in
t-shirts and shorts people aren't going
to take him serious they're not going to
give them what they want I wonder how
many police they can just show up and
like Sam from the FBI and start
interrogating them like at a bar
probably like oh definitely if they've
had a few drinks you could definitely
well but people are gonna recognize you
that's the only problem that's another
thing you start taking out a big big
cases you can't wear cases anymore in
the FBI your face gets out there your
name too yeah yeah